- Hey, guys.
I hope you're having a great
weekend or the start to one.
Curiosity 180 created
this video on YouTube.
One of the things I want
to do is start using
my YouTube channel a little bit more
to put on people that
are doing creative work
around content that is involving of me
and this was an incredible
effort you're about to see.
Tremendous work.
Based on how many followers
they have and views,
they're getting their
hustle, getting going,
and so hopefully a bunch
of you can reach out
and do stuff with each other
and so it's a little bit
of that old Biz Dev Sunday
kind of thing where just a
lot of fun to put somebody on
who made something amazing.
Guys, gals, I love the video.
It's super rad.
Here it is.
(upbeat music)
- [Narrator] Gary,
Gary, Viner, Vinerchuck?
Vay-- What?
(static)
Vaynerchuck, okay.
(upbeat music)
Gary Vaynerchuck is undoubtedly the symbol
for hustle, execution,
and digital advertising.
He is the CEO and
co-founder of Vayner Media,
and an early investor of great ideas,
such as Tumblr, SnapChat, and Twitter.
He is a four-time New York
Times best-selling author
and inspires millions
with his YouTube show,
The Daily Vee.
To find out how he
achieved his grand status,
we have to dive into the origin
story of a young Gary Vee.
Gary was born in the former Soviet Union,
and witnessed his older
relatives being imprisoned
and ostracized for being Jewish.
In hopes for a better
life, Gary and his parents
immigrated to the United States.
With very little money,
Gary's dad made ends meet
by working as a stock
boy in a liquor store.
Gary experienced difficulty
adapting to the American culture
and was notorious for
being a terrible student.
Even though education wasn't his calling,
he quickly found he had a
different special ability.
Gary was keen on observing human behavior.
He had an intuitive
feeling on what factors
motivated people to buy, sell, and trade.
His introduction to
entrepreneurship started
when he was only six years old.
He would run to his neighbor's property,
pull flowers out of their garden,
ring their front doorbell,
and then sell it back to them.
He also had eight lemonade
stands around New Jersey
and had his friends working for him
at each of the locations.
His major breakthrough
came when he turned 13
and started selling baseball cards,
making thousands of dollars every weekend
with the developing understanding
of the concept of supply and demand.
By the time Gary was a young adult,
his dad saved up enough money
to buy his own liquor store.
He made Gary quit all his other ventures
to work for him for minimum wage.
Gary worked every day
and observed how his dad
interacted with his customers.
He quickly realized his expertise
in selling baseball cards
can transfer to selling wine.
He soon became an oenophile,
or a lover and expert of wines.
When Gary was in college, he
was introduced to the internet,
which was then known as the
information superhighway.
Gary saw this as an opportunity
to increase wine sales,
and thus, winelibrary.com was born.
Armed with a vast amount
of emotional intelligence
and experience with
early internet projects
like winelibrary.com and Wine Library TV,
Gary decided to create his
own digital marketing agency.
Gary is now the CEO of Vayner Media,
an agency that is filled
with digital ninjas
who excel in story telling,
branding, and marketing.
However, despite all of his success,
Gary takes the time to
produce motivational content
for anyone who needs push
in the right direction.
If you haven't yet, we
highly encourage you
to check out his channel
where you can find
some inspiration for your journey,
and hopefully, you too can mold yourself
into a legendary entrepreneur.
This video focused on Gary Vaynerchuck,
in hopes that his hustle and hard work
motivates and inspires our viewers
to go after what they want and to focus
on being happy.
Today, November 14th, is also his birthday
and the launch of his sneakers,
Gary V 001 and 001 by K-Swiss.
Congratulations, and great hustle.
(soft music)
- Hey, guys.
Hope you enjoyed it.
Lot of fun, pretty good, right?
So this weekend, the Jets have a buy,
so nothing on Sunday.
What do you like to do
on your team's buy week?